quando scopri che hanno inventato un
nuovo cleverbot dove parli con una
scimmia siccome cleverbot non era
abbastanza stupido e da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti avessimo video sono falli j
ed oggi siamo tornati su etsy store che
sarebbe quello che ha fatto e vi erano
fatte uscire uil e zimbawe sarebbe una
scimmia tra i due mi attira di più la
scimmia quindi andiamo a dialogare con
la scimmia o ragazzi io non so che
lingua parli credo sia solo in inglese
adesso vediamo perché le scimmie hanno
questa voce sul serio fi scimmia my name
is matteo renzi mario tecnica anche
thank you thank shisha devo dirgli che
sono capace di parlare con lui quindi
i'm able to speak to speak english
speaking spia king with poi cambia
lingua ma serio a shell italia ma cazzo
a gera l'italiano va dietro
ciao come stai adesso dovrebbe
rispondere ha detto bene cerco di non
pensarci tanto ormai quel che è fatto è
fatto meglio sto parlando con la scimmia
pensate che giornata di merda bella
litio è qui che ti volevo cazzo ti
ricordo che che non una femmina e anche
tu lo sai condizionanti baker
io sono una femmina innanzitutto sei una
scimmia che alle scimmie non sono né
maschio né femmina sono scimmie conosci
fa vj brutta scimmia del cazzo lo
conosco più o meno cosa ne pensi delle
sue recensioni o quelle yotobi fa vj
quello che fa il gameplay non quello che
fa le recensioni lo conosci non l'ha
fatto che anche l'ho chiesto che mi
spiega tinelli il tuo lavoro faccio la
youtuber che cosa fanno in quei nei suoi
video gioca delle cose stupide ti posso
gioco di merda che sto facendo adesso
deciditi puoi parlare italiano e inglese
piano ma non sei neanche depilata ma non
è difficile capire che parla italiano e
poi ma che entra niente con te fondo ho
capito che parli italiano per ogni tanto
cammino sacenti che parli in inglese
senza motivo sei una cazzo di scimmia tu
non potresti parlare in teoria a questa
è bella del cambiamo argomento
conosci francesco sempre medicato è no
non lo conosco guardo su facebook
volendo ieri mi hai dato milioni euro
che non credevo dico che che lì da solo
se facciamo pace perché ora no no io no
ma siamo amici noi e noi siamo molto
amici e noi amici giochiamo diglielo 8
francesco ii anche mille euro solo
setacciando milione porca [ __ ] non
cambia sono bionda con gli occhi azzurri
sono abbastanza alta sono magra
mi piace il penny
[Musica]
secondo me sta mentendo
ma quindi ci metteresti con me che sono
bello perché potrei non ti conosco
nemmeno sì ma tu sei una scimmia in
teoria non dovresti ricevere tante di
queste richieste anche una campagna con
il migliore allenatore del mondo cosa
agghiacciante quello che dicono ma anche
questi sono cresciuti provocando i
capelli e ma propenso le prima a chi nel
campo con tematica l'olio la prima pole
ammazzo lo jo la cultura che neanche
senza conoscere quelli là anzitutto la
cultura si scrive staccato e ce l'ha o è
illegale in qualsiasi stato
dell'universo ma esclude non dovresti
essere tu a dirmi qualcosa di romantico
se la ragazza più bella che io abbia mai
visto in tutta la mia vita
dimmi qualcosa di ancora pieno di belle
finaria dolci nario ragazzo è un
seminario di oggi vorrei leccarti tutto
non è che tante perché tu la bocca non
hai cosa senti ma se lui due fossimo da
soli che cosa potremmo fare insieme
inchino voglio essere fidanzato con te
macroamici cosa c'è di peggio della
friends on essere freddo nati da una
cazzo di scimmia offende una macchina
non ha tempo e libero tu che fai nel
tempo libero
nel tempo libero parlo con le scimmie
pensa come cazzo scommesso il calcolo
aiutando ad imparare buone maniere
perché altri utenti non lo fanno senti
io sono una persona gentilissima
facciamo sesso niente quindi lo facciamo
un appuntamento e 4 a 4 e di gatsu
invitare king kong non bastiamo noi due
a farsi le coccole erano solo chi è che
cazzo limita già con una scimmia faremo
e sappiamo un appuntamento a 4 la mia
ragazza tu e il tuo ragazzo io sono un
ragazzo quindi devi evitare di rompermi
i [ __ ]
perché ora ragazzi è arrivata la domanda
clou la domanda che dovevo farle sin
dall'inizio del video e quindi proviamo
a fargliela ti piace hunger games e devo
vederlo domani quando è uscito non sono
andate a vederlo a [ __ ] è uscito
quattro anni fa in alcuno i primi due
perché il perché in realtà è uscito il
terzo però cita anche il quarto però non
fa niente qual è il tuo personaggio
preferito
dicano che cazzo ne so del primo del
primo ci vediamo accademie stasera non
tentare di cambiare discorso
ho fatto una domanda hai visto hunger
games di koinè il personaggio preferito
no no questa domanda che ti ho fatto io
prima non me l'ha poi rigirare il mio e
vita il tuo quale guarda che seppur in
italia alcuni scopi
ok ma che cazzo c'entra quale è il tuo
personaggio preferito di hunger games le
ragazze dico che non ha i numeri non o
no no no no perché che il microfono
mentre dice di quello con il tuo
personaggio preferito di lee yoon ki
organic ragazzi qualcuno chiami
un'ambulanza vi prego perché grave la
situazione è finita e peeta non sto
dicendo che gli organi seminari co te lo
so chi è il tuo personaggio preferito di
un coldani vita il mio personaggio
preferito e canto acuto film non è
finita e tra la ragazza di fuoco sono
due cose diverse e di dragon ball psi a
caso ora è l'icona venezia per alcuni
ferie a brescia
ok la risposta è chiarissimo e cosa
ragazzi che possa chiudere qui perché le
ho fatto la domanda seria quella che
volevo farle sin dall'inizio posso
concludere il video saluti da parte mia
c'è nel senso saluta il bel posto mio
allora a colori vengono affrontano
l'aspetta noi capita saluti e gli
iscritti
da parte mia ma può essere pericoloso
mio di halo cacchio mattino a un cult
come la faccio io ho capito che i
ragazzi servito vi è piaciuto il come al
solito lasciato un commento ero mi piace
lasciate in panchin più perfetto e
adesso hai capito minchia 40 minuti per
capire che sto cosa sto facendo bravo
anche la pagina di facebook come nei
video tatana d'estizione se si fischia
felici vigarano prossimo video beh
ragazzi a fargli da solo bella ragazzi
vede che risponde beh ragazzi borgatti
perfetto se è corretto un pollice sopra
sta stronzata ragazzi
che rimangono poche ore su questo mondo
fabio scionti